okay here we are back on the okay Doris
how would Lincoln have handled today's
Republican Party well first of all I
must say I always hate it when
Republicans go we're the party of
Lincoln Party's changed their whole
dynamics and as it completely flips they
should be they should be forced to drop
that were the party of Lincoln that's
not at all the same party right no it is
not the same party but I must say just
listening to you tonight it made me so
good after this an acrimonious week to
laugh tonight and it's really important
to have that to do this Lincoln used to
say the way you whistle off sadness is
through humor he was able to tell funny
stories he I don't see a sense of humor
in our current president I mean it's a
really missing element but I mean
there's a big up to you when laughing
with it what if Lincoln were here today
what he would be talking about is how to
reconcile these different parts of the
country we can't let it be that other
people are different from us and we
don't care about what they're thinking
and feeling we have to remember that a
majority of the people want an inclusive
country they want immigration they want
Medicare they want aid to education they
want mobility they want the lack of
inequities to be dealt with and planet
and they care about a healthy planet
very much
[Music]
those people who want those things go
out and vote you're so right power
begets power there's a spent President
Trump has not expanded his base it's
still in the 30% so we don't have to be
so upset about this if we can do
something about look more people are
running for office and now the young
people are excited more women than ever
before take heart in that and get them
to the polls get them to the polls Jeff
should the government be doing more to
ensure that kids facing hunger are able
to get access to food oh yeah absolutely
I mean this is you know where government
can really you know lend a hand
now I had I've been working with on the
hunger issue for over 30 years on you
have yeah and I've had wonderful success
by not going up the up against the feds
you know I've done a lot of lobbying
there but working with the governors
they seem to be you know a lot more into
the people a lot of these governors
don't know that there's a billion
dollars of federal funding that's there
on their table if they have programs in
place to you know well just hungry kids
but if they don't have those programs in
place in that well it's the same thing
with Medicaid expansion they've got lots
of money on the table from the federal
government in Obamacare the Republican
governors chose not to use that money
why again liberal tears because it was
not costing them anything but what's
what feels odd to me - they'll I
consider myself a Democrat but it's kind
of a isn't that a conservative feeling
to go more local rather than looking at
them and that's what I bring up about
sure our environment rather than waiting
for those guys I mean you definitely got
to do your voting for sure but engage in
another kind of way you know this we
have another whole powerful way of
engaging in all these issues you know to
take it kind of personally don't say I'm
gonna vote for the guy and then you made
your vote now I can I don't have to feel
guilty I've made my you can engage right
I mean all the changes in our society
have come when it correlates from the
anti-slavery movement the women's
movement the civil rights movement the
progressive movement it's the citizens
make it and then the leaders channel
with it you were talking before about
government versus leaders we can't fix
we waiting for the leaders we have to
take the responsibility ourselves we are
the citizens of this country in the
morning and I saw this woman who said
something really interesting because it
seems to me that passion is what we're
looking we're looking for people to be
passionate about the environment and she
made something really an interesting
observation she said passion is the
flame that comes from rubbing some
sticks together you got to get in there
and get into it and chew it up and
relatives have we have plenty of passion
right now but it's the wrong kind of
passion right it's a passionate and
intense hatred well it's the other I
just I mean I wish I could be as hopeful
as you Doris but when you when you look
at the rhetoric right now it seems very
similar to me to the rhetoric of the
1850s eighteen eighteen 60s in which
people are talking about the other part
of the country as if it were another
country when people are saying we would
prefer to be run by a foreign agent in
right though then we would buy a
Democrat yes we are at a point where the
discourse has curdled to such an extent
that it can lead especially now again if
the illegitimate of this system
continues like we you are talking about
the popular vote issue in the electoral
college issue president selected
gerrymander if this continues we could
have a real legitimacy crisis in this
country where people will actually turn
to violence and you can see it beginning
you can see it people wanting to vent
this anger in the sense of in the
streets well by going up against people
in the elevators or in Bristol you can't
we need to have a constitutional
amendment to end citizens united we have
to overturn that we need to have
the local state every time you do that
you trigger the other tribes even
greater and greater levels of passion
that's the problem then we have to have
the passion that's equal to that I feel
like my mentioned Bucky fuller another
thing that he said that really makes a
lot of sense as far as what we were
talking about he says when you want to
change something you don't have to go
right up against it
he says come up with something that
makes what you're trying to change
obsolete you know don't you know spend
all this energy in this anger that anger
can we can we can shift that and get
involved with how we see it you have to
talk to each other I mean I think that's
right that's a lack of communication I
mean when I was saying earlier and saw
that you thought it was absurd I think
when I look at the meter in a certain
way because I'm still basically
right-of-center
I see and hear things that you may not
see in here and when I say that I'm
hearing those things it's useful for you
to say
I hear you as opposed to it's absurd is
it what is marriage counseling
[Applause]
countries are
[Applause]
you know I read an interesting thing I
think it was from our sometimes Fred
Glenn Greenwald saying that like on
MSNBC they get ratings every segment
okay wait a minute
okay by the minute no yes they're called
the minutes you get them broken down for
a minute so you can follow where you
lose your voter right okay so who on
MSNBC is ever going to risk their show
by saying something that doesn't exactly
aligned with what the audience already
wants to hear and think so that's kind
of a hermetically sealed bubble - it's
just one with a lot more facts where
they're usually on the right side of
issues but not the whole time no and
sometimes you can get into this
framework for example I'm starting to
say about race with gender that rights
really upsetting a lot of other people
in the country you're hearing this who
you don't you wouldn't say that to their
face but I can't I can't be agreeing
with them and go oh for [ __ ] sake and
turn it off really I can't because
everything is like what do you think
Chris you're so right it's like what a
surprise we've all communicating online
and on screens and that's a very
different experience when you're talking
to someone looking at their eyes in
their face and their body language oh
and where you actually do have to
accommodate them a little bit david
jolly are you going to follow other
principle conservatives and vote
democratic in the midterm
ooh hot seat for you david jolly and now
so look i love that question because i
came out in October of last year and
said I think Democrats should take the
house I think we'll be safer in the
divided government but Bill it builds on
everything we've talked about Barack
Obama talked about a post partisan
America but he tried to do it through a
two-party system I left the party about
five weeks ago
I don't think the future is between the
two parties and I'll tell you the
inflection point we're expecting our
first child and among adults we can have
this perspective and what I would say is
this sure among adults we can have this
Republican on Republican fight nearly
three years ago I stood on the House
floor as a sitting Republican member of
Congress and called on Donald Trump to
drop out of the presidential race and I
have never lost my voice I have never
gone silent whereas all of my Republican
colleagues have they're tough because I
mean you know people are currently your
whole life your parents are probably
Republicans yeah look it's incredibly
tough but here's here's what I will tell
you I hope our daughter learns two
things from our example the first is for
three years we fought a fight for
something we truly believed in that the
Republicans could answer to better
angels but the other lesson I hope our
daughter learns is this there are fights
that at times wiser men and women walk
away from and this is a fight as you go
to start over somebody else can fight
you the dignity the Republican puts
there is not my fighters there's two
parties the Democrats and the traitors
and it's not it's not a big issue
you know how you know I often read that
Paul Ryan quote where he's that they got
him on tape behind closed doors saying I
think it's somebody else says you know
there's two Republicans who are I think
are on Putin's panel McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy said there's new Republicans on
Putin's payroll Trump and Rohrabacher
and Paul Ryan doesn't go oh my god let's
go to the FBI he goes okay that doesn't
really how they say that's how we know
we're fit I mean that's not true okay
Soledad I had a question for you well
why don't they use their power like like
Jeff Flake is actually one most powerful
people on earth he's a politician right
right and now he's going to have a nice
cushy Republican job have a nice job
like this look isn't this more fun being
with us for doing TV I say hey call your
Congressman here's what I will tell you
and this is something look and as we
have these academic and intelligent
conversations about why why why why why
at some point we get to judge the
leadership integrity and the moral fiber
of our political leaders and we get to
say you made a wrong decision and you
leave and that's where we are right now
in the moment all right okay final
question Soledad O'Brien if or when roe
v-- wade is overturned how should
progressives respond ooh with protection
a lot of saddest things is to hear
senator Collins talk about that as a
non-issue when you listen to her very
long and tortured delivery of her speech
today to talk about you know I'm not
worried about roe v wade and I think
there are lots of people who are worried
about roe v wade I think she's very
wrong on that issue I don't know I don't
know what the I don't know what the
solution to that is but you know
hopefully don't motivate people to get
to the polls can I can I suggest
something very the other liberals would
actually be better off if roe versus
wade disappeared because then they would
actually have to
go to the people and ask for Democratic
majorities and in fact there are
democratic parties in most Western
canals EU you're not gonna get anybody
pressure
[Laughter]
[Applause]